Pakistan is convulsing with political
unrest after dozens of security forces
smashed their way into a local court and
took former prime minister Imran Khan
into custody seen here in a wheelchair
surrounded by Shields and wearing a
bulletproof helmet
Khan is Accused in several corruption
cases ranging from improper property
deals to allegations he unlawfully sold
State gifts charges he denies and says
are politically motivated
his supporters have reacted with Fury
protesting in several cities Pakistan's
all-powerful military looms large over
the nation's politics having ruled the
country for more than half of its
existence and have given their backing
to the current prime minister Shabbat
Sharif
but since Khan was ousted from Power
last year what he says was an
orchestrated plot the nuclear-armed and
strategic Washington Ally has been
spiraling into Political chaos